Audiences expect to be riveted, surprised,
or simply astonished when a blockbuster film
comes to theaters.
But what about the stories, messages, and
deeper meanings that being told below the
surface?
Most films are exactly what they seem to be,
but every so often, a writer or director will
craft a hit film that is much, much more than
meets the eye.
Here are Screenrant’s 10 Amazing Hidden
Messages in Your Favorite Movies.
Iron Man
Jeff Bridges got the chance to show a darker
side when cast as the villain of Iron Man,
but the visual effects team made it clear
which of the actor’s roles was their favorite.
When Pepper Potts is secretly looking for
evidence on his computer, the documents show
weapons shipped on a vessel named “Lebowski”
- a nod to Bridges’ role in The Big Lebowski
released a decade earlier.
His character’s name is also contained in
a barcode for all to see, and exact quotes
from the movie are easy to read in the fine
print.
Pepper and the viewers had just a fraction
of a second to read all of the hidden messages,
since she’s interrupted by none other than
The Dude himself.
Captain America
In Marvel’s version of World War II, it
was HYDRA and Red Skull who posed the real
threat to the Allies.
The villain even shrugs off Adolf Hitler,
claiming to be doing real research while the
German leader wastes his time seeking mystical
artifacts.
When audiences remember that director Joe
Johnston worked in visual effects and art
direction for Raiders of the Lost Ark, the
real meaning of this line is clear.
At the very least, it’s a nod to the plot
of Indiana Jones’ first adventure, and at
most, a playful hint that the archeologist
existed alongside the Marvel Universe decades
ahead of time.
The Matrix
The idea that humanity’s idea of reality
is decaying, or is already erased wasn’t
a totally original thought when The Matrix
hit theatres.
Once Neo is removed from his artificial life,
Morpheus shows him the world as it really
is.
That line is taken word for word from “Simulacra
and Simulation” by Jean Baudrillard, a book
that can be seen in Neo’s apartment.
Considering Neo’s search for meaning, it’s
no coincidence that the book is open on a
chapter “On Nihilism” - the belief that…all
beliefs are meaningless.
Eventually, the philosophy changes, with Neo
accepting that he is “The One”, and even
being resurrected by the ‘Holy Trinity’.
The religious themes don’t stop there, so
viewers can take their pick.
Jurassic Park
Before the scientists of Jurassic Park had
learned the dangers of growing dinosaurs firsthand,
they developed a unique method to control
breeding.
Ian Malcolm warned that growing only female
dinosaurs wouldn’t work forever, but Alan
Grant had already proven the theory to audiences.
During the group’s bumpy arrival on the
island, Alan struggles with his seatbelt.
Why?
He’s trying to connect two female ends.
Rather than swapping buckles or giving up,
he fashions his own solution, just as mother
nature would later in the movie.
Grant, like Life, “found a way”.
Robocop
With the star of this near-future action film
advertised as “part man, part machine,”
it’s hard to see how the story could truly
take inspiration from the Bible.
But the events of the movie are a clear match:
Alex Murphy is a hero in a corrupt city, who
is killed, resurrected, and emerges as a robotic
savior.
Director Paul Verhoeven confirmed that a Biblical
allegory was his goal, even including a scene
of Murphy walking on water in the film’s
third act.
According to the Dutch filmmaker, an invincible
hero who handed out bullets instead of forgiveness
was his idea of “an American Jesus,” dishing
out brutal justice in a world torn apart by
violent crime.
Serenity
Every Firefly fans know that Joss Whedon’s
canceled TV show was given a second life,
and a conclusion on the big screen.
But when Serenity was greenlit by Universal.
The crew realized that Fox, believing the
property to be dead, had destroyed the sets
– meaning they had to be rebuilt from scratch.
The film’s budget had to cover the new ship,
but Whedon made light of the situation, stencilling
storage containers with the words “REUSABLE
CONTAINER: DO NOT DESTROY” in large letters.
Let’s hope they took the message to heart.
Harold and Kumar
The story of two stoners in search of burgers
made John Cho and Kal Penn overnight stars,
but Cho previously turned heads in the movie
Better Luck Tomorrow, director Justin Lin’s
acclaimed story of over-achieving Asian American
teens.
Lin has confirmed the movie is a prequel story
for Fast & Furious hero Han (“Honn”),
but the same can’t be said for Cho’s character.
Someone on the set of Harold & Kumar was clearly
a fan, and found a clever way of working the
title into the script.
Terminator 2
When James Cameron’s sci-fi sequel hit theaters
in 1991, it did so with a theme song: “You
Could Be Mine” by Guns N’ Roses.
But that wasn’t always the plan.
James Cameron has never admitted he made the
film with the band in mind, but there are
some obvious clues.
Not only is John Connor’s best friend wearing
an L.A. Guns t-shirt – one of the two bands
which would lead to GNR – but when the Terminator
finally arrives to take on the villain, he
reveals his gun hidden in a box of, you guessed
it, roses (31:30).
Arnold Schwarzenegger personally convinced
the band to sign on, making sure the movie’s
sales pitch was a successful one.
The Lost World
Jurassic Park was a difficult adventure to
beat, but director Steven Spielberg tackled
the challenge anyway, removing dinosaurs from
the island, and dropping them in San Diego.
The added spectacle wasn’t a hit with every
fan, but the director had gotten the chance
to finally film the sequences and plot beats
that he couldn’t fit in the first movie.
The Lost World ended with the dinosaurs traveling
back home, and letting Spielberg finally take
on the role of a fan – literally.
Look closely at the TV reflection, and the
director can be seen with a bowl of popcorn
in his lap, and a smile on his face.
Prometheus
The religious themes and imagery of Ridley
Scott’s sort-of-prequel to Alien begin in
the opening scene, with an alien Engineer
sacrificing himself to seed Earth with life
– an idea seen in Greek, Roman and Aztec
religions.
But it’s not the most obvious message.
When the film’s characters uncover an ancient
map to a distant moon, LV-223, the film’s
Christian heroine sees it as an invitation
to meet her creator in person.
But instead of answers, the crew finds violent
creatures and an Engineer determined to destroy
all human life on Earth.
It may be unexpected, but apply the Bible
to the story, and some answers are possible.
The moon LV-223 is likely a reference to Leviticus
22:3, a warning from God that “…if any
of your descendants is unclean, and yet comes
near these sacred offerings…they shall perish
before the Lord.”
To make the twist on Christianity even clearer,
Scott had planned to explain that an Engineer
sent to save mankind 2,000 years ago was crucified
instead, but decided that was a little too
on the nose.
So what do you think of our list?
Did we miss any of your favorite hidden messages
or secret meanings in movies?
Let us know in our comment section and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for more
videos like this one.